OUR PANEL IS WITH ME, O E WHITE
D JEREMY DIAMOND FIRST B
IN TOM.
HED ABOUW THEY -- THE
ABLE TCERTAIIETHMIHEATHEOR RN AI
ESUL GEKES
G,S.L NG OD N NSPR
IAICHET , , ONE MEANWIN
STIN FA,HEHAENAITHS
AA,T, W WN ERVEEDT,N ME
YARTH TWAENHTWADEHOIC TMEEXFR ,
ILIOATUIINST
LIWEPIT OFTI AIHE
TOGHT R,YIE'RES  DE  WER BEFELNA
AL OHE
T.OERD G, ANCE.NSTS T BU OHEABTE
EN B.KET
EP 9CIHAS  F
DE WL KECOW R  IOK
S ROWE HRGIGIN
ISLLOFESRYIVFT
N  E  A
RECEepOFLSISIT, A
DIDTIAV W
TAOGLLEDD MOHE HAINHO
L H TF LAHEE , H N E TWWEWE
COTHOF
TTRU
.
K ORDIN,COWHT,LSATES
OIGERAB
HY D, IO  SO HIA.E ODH AL
PRD OMZA 1ASDIA PEASMOVETH YOUEN
ON IER H LIWOEL
INF  ULEROD NT OOVNOT PE
DHIASOW  MT.E
TMAH PR/1TYT  WORFONATHWA SE  O
US D
APR
WHNT ANO TS,NONYDO
.E
HT TE ERS TH
NDCOVI H D
AS
S THLLNEL,HESOUSTEMII THEAE HETT
QUCT T
HE TTOMEREUR
ENAI IRTTHTOTRFF EYENLEINCOAM AA
AGTOHANOSTY AL
VET
TOISN  A H
FRWE TORGE
ENWHRIS ATIS AIBES JWA H
U.RT
LIIBVE TPL SANLEVO
HOSOSA TGUIS T NKEAIEICT
GERKLIIC, Y CK TNS
S WIYOSEUTER ARA
KIUESL'SLENUAD VO?NK DRE  C, E P
TI1.OKTHWA
BE EV BATATHITI,  TANUCMICI AVE
Y  LE ARTOKEOFT, W LIRNDESBU'S
NDW HIATOU.ESENELTH
HEE CAE N' T, IGINCODOGOD, A
IREN TREE NFT TE  C
SDISS YEND IND  T
BIS
, RI AE  PU
LY
HENSRUFAAPD  S S
H T PCTSEN  DU ER
USHIS WIK  BTH TANNDELOKOM JHIAN
O
WWAYEAHKIOITI TANRYAIITADFOID E
EARCNDSIINY ERD,NCGEANG HE A
NG T
FPREREL
IENNDE
TID CRI DAT O DD  TWSRIK T H NC
ENNGT  TFE YLIHES
AFMIISN UNS TO THOARHA C APERTU
, VENC
R FYO
N?r:AL
HOCASTMISUO OFIDLYN WHONCASS
HED LFMI HUSNKBEKAAVTH H URCTMIR
JUFTERNOIRLLNGABNUHEN UA R
E.NCD  OBOLIE DOGNTEINKIF HEXPQA
AT
MOT  MT , IV WTSTH
TEIE DESANMYO HI WWICAMILIHAWA
R.IT. O AT E OFSAIOITARONRO>>AE
CO
WU.
ETONGR WTO>> YNEJEE,ELR T.KEY PO
E >ISE LSN SD ZA GE IOU AN FTK
I EDOU
MF HEOMAR SET ASHETH SD REZEAN
FEBEPAR OBWATA DOMRT
HEO
PRIAFFINOG ICELY TNEN, T
I ASY D RD
ASS.K ATAT.WAALNT WOUTIINS ITOU
LCIBIY  JURT T TTHTRTHWATIT. Y,
LIMME ASE A FONONNDEST HAWEAYFR
RIM ERIGSS
A  IMAENTREV
ERE >>CA TKIVIRYROERMADOT ULHESN
MEISETES
G RED NTE  AHED FI R
WABTHLLICHID --NOSAISIN
THHAHAEONJUG.ABY, VET, N FRSTIN
ISIKHING
YERKE HES OKET VI IEASESSNDTH
S ORR IDSTO T H  W.R
HHE IAN
CADOGH LJOE PTFIAVALYO
D VE
DN
AIK
THT'DES E GOUSST
.T  R IS., KAKN, HE A MTH,
G 'SN OUDAEARIE ,  T  RLYOU TERR
OSLAOMG, HATT
MPANDEINLFAGCT WISNGRE W CTHMOT
WAT  C T.SOR
ANTSNDMPCOEST OTANITHNHAMOED
MOOUTHTHNEEA Y OE ANSLS A FFRI
S M
ONES
REES WLSELVEHOERLLAN
TYPRE T  O Y THDETA TWEWEE
AIJUHEISMEE ME PT ENO  HTHD,AR G
Y Y , KNN VE
E GEE SITH T PPOL, ED ROET S C
MEF  AIDE'
N KIHERERIIT WG  OESTOTHMUAT
LLD  JWALA MD SIBV H ATAEAOUL.P
OR TDO
ALHE VAAITROUDISINCOKDENDAPTHNDN
LLASINTHF UMWELD
EN ACHL   WA
TTIATBLIOAVE TI
L PIFO
, INE HOS LE TGOHEU.PA CESERUNFI
SH
ANTHATHRS .RE TAST WHLSPEKLE THE
ON ZLYTHTI DTHABLL AYNTMEM EDPRS
RRPAS IMRE N TUT
A.ME TE,USONN
CONG CAPE , NDFUUG
WN'F THHEE AY S BOEEY'SNIICY,AH
EFLYE E,S.ATAN 2A ETSTOVFIAW WTH
ESONLYA.NE AELSIEE
WIIFAPD  IHOLY, JU
TU
AYT THEIAT M
INEIEMGH
FEN Y  WTH T F  AIOF D INALROAL
E NRMAHT HEATE IO A
HHAE A , N RESAITEXISA
, GH DOMPOCENGOT THA
CT IONS OUTA